this is the first a delivery in months
to reach the kaga bandura refugee camp
up until now the runway had been blocked
by survivors seeking shelter from war
and persecution
those who've ended up here have horrific
stories to tell of murdered family
members rape and kidnappings of entire
villages burnt to the ground UN soldiers
patrolled the area here that provides
enough security to make sure aid arrives
safely UNICEF has built a temporary
school where the thousands of children
stranded here receive lessons
lucila Shue is one of them she's 12
years old my father is dead the Seleka
killed my grandfather
so we fled from our village I've been
living here for three years her teacher
tells us the rest of her story the
Muslim Seleka rebels kidnapped her
mother Lucy hasn't seen her since
everybody here is severely traumatized
UNICEF at least tries to create some
sense of normality in the camp even if
it's an almost impossible task the
humanitarian needs are increasing sadly
more and more people are under attack
our IDPs where now we have 600,000
people who are internally displaced
within the country which is what it was
at the peak of the crisis in 2014 so
there's still a lot to do
the last brutal attack in kaga Banda row
happened about a year ago many parts of
the city have been abandoned those who
survived are now squeezed in at the camp
at the airport along with thousands of
refugees more than 30,000 people are
living in the refugee camp of kaga
Bandaru many of them have homes nearby
but to walk home means risking their
lives violence can erupt at any time
even UN troops only managed to broker
fragile peace the majority of the
country has been ruled by approximately
20 different armed groups fighting each
other for control
the frontlines between the warring rebel
groups run right through the middle of
the city UN troops have taken a position
on the only bridge and check vehicles
for weapons but so far they've been
unable to stop the bitter fighting the
chances for peace are slim the conflict
may be rooted in religion and ethnic
origin but it's fueled by the fight over
the country's resources land gold and
diamonds